Rainbow six experts in close quarters
battle and hostage-rescue
assembled from Special Forces teams
around the world the counterterrorism
units these are the elite French
operator
which maneuvers a shock drone drill
spinning up this one can deliver
electric probes to distract hostiles or
incapacitate devices if you think nobody
can get in
chifuyu wrong
we need to keep moving Montana his arms
with an expandable sheetal label to give
protection from small firearms and close
combat attacks right where nobody wants
to go kill Stefan first stay behind me
ready to go
operator head equipped with a stim
pistol doc is able to precisely deliver
a close-range healing shot here take
this when things go south cover me
doc is the one to give a second chance I
know to get yourselves hurt rook can
provide additional armor packs to the
team
each vest can stop ballistics from
piercing the chest cavity quite handy
when it's your own holding the shots
gee IGN operators know that saving a
life is more important than one's own